so is the Bible corrupted it's finished
okay yes Jesus corrupted it is yes okay
now you make a big deal about believing
the Koran as opposed to believe in the
Bible and how it's important to believe
the Koran and you know because it's
because of the hadith the half azores
and all this business yeah only one I
won't say this one thing Jesus didn't
say believe the Bible because this is
going to be an infallible words
translated in your language in fact if
you read in Revelation Jesus says that
whoever adds to this word then God will
add the curses that are written in the
book to them and if anyone takes away
from this word then God will take their
name out of the book of life
so Jesus already knew that the Bible was
going to be corrupted Jesus never told
us to believe in a book jesus said this
this is the work of God not to study
history in church history and who wrote
the book of Matthew but this is the work
of God that ye believe on Him whom he
hath sent and anyone can do that
you don't have to be a church historian
to believe in where is it where is it no
contradiction arey that the very fact
that you doing you read it on the books
you say to us we should not mind in what
Bokova screwface but yet you read in a
from a book so we can read the words of
Jesus and believe the words of Jesus
what's your names written in the book
what's your name sir my name is Richard
I'm Ali Richard our
the question I wanted to ask was the
following you claimed and I admire you
honestly that the Bible is corrupted but
the Pope went that he made I was going
to make
well that your source of information of
Jesus's divinity his resurrection his
death is based on a book but the very
book you claim is corrupted how do you
know besides a red letter Bible how do
you know even the red letter Bible
itself was written or said by Jesus
because if a book is corrupted this is
my hair after a risk if I give you a
bottle of water with a drop of poison in
it you will not drink it because the
harm I caused to your body
how are you consuming a scripture but
you claim to be corrupted for your soul
because that's the wrong analogy to use
the idea of water with poisoning is the
wrong analogy because the truth that is
in the Bible is vindicated and it is
authenticated by the person who reads it
by the Holy Spirit that comes to the
person visits the person when they read
it is an atheist read the Bible not
believing in God and something's told me
that the words of Jesus in the Sermon on
the Mount were God's words and they had
an immediate impact on my life and when
I responded to them I met with the
person who spoke those words but really
because he's alive that's the meaning of
the resurrection is that jesus is alive
now and he can speak to us directly
that's why we believe in a living
Messiah not in a dead book okay okay
rich I just want to make something just
a point very clear because do we believe
that Satan is our enemy yes okay all
that tells us to take him as our enemy
yeah
yes what does Satan want us to do what's
that why is the pinnacle actuator would
want us to maybe commit adultery robbed
murder but what is the pinnacle of the
sins that he would want us to do not
pray or worship other than not pray okay
as far as I know not pray to God but
instead worship Him thank you thank you
so you've raised a very important point
in the scene with his stump yeah
we believe the Shaitaan attested in 67
ways yeah he tries to gets us to commit
shirk worshiping underpin but if not
then he tries to get us to do innovation
if my innovation majors if not matrices
minuses etc etcetera etcetera
now I want ask you a question Richard
how do you know the vision that you had
was not Satan because what he has got
you to do because what we did is we
broke it down you said you admitted this
one I admire your honesty and
you'll be in here as well that the book
is not reliable and therefore we set you
if it's not reliable how are you getting
you reading it and you said it's a
corrupted story corrupted forgive me
forgive me for me you said is corrupted
and then you reset you if it's corrupted
then how are you leaving it together
information about Jesus if it's chronic
then you said will rely on the Holy
Spirit now the question that would want
to ask us this how do we know it was not
Satan that visited you gave you this
inner feeling that you in return have
done exactly what he wanted you to do
worship other than him other than God
Almighty why the trial do you know how
do you know that no how do you know I
know no how do you know I know how do
you know why that's different yeah how
you know it's different from what I know
so when I talk about my experience yeah
you can you can you can accept it or you
can reject it you have free to do that
how do you know he's not Satan that's I
know about my personal experiences
I knew Satan before Jesus met with me
because there know what Satan looks like
we appeared to me yeah I had idea I know
there are demons yeah and you can see
them they sometimes appear to you and
they're evil stuff they're evil and
they're devious if satan wants to come
and make you do something do you think
is gonna come looking evil organized
true yeah so how do you know it wasn't
Satan this is very much okay because
jesus said you shall know a tree by its
fruits so he says they said no he said
you can apply it to your life and I've
been a Christian out for thirty years
and before I was a Christian there was
no fruit and what was the fruit in my
life was thorns
yea and thistles that was the fruit in
my life I was selfish
after I had this meeting with who you
say was a spirit that could be Satan
hiding himself behind and tell me it's
Jesus after I had that experience I've
had fruit in my life which his figs and
grapes and his stuff that is lasting and
good yeah and it's based on the change
in my life and the peace that I got in
my life Satan doesn't give give peace
Satan gives turmoil he makes people
agitated only God can give you peace
lasting peace the world can't give you
peace the peace just of the world just
gives you gives you stuff too you want
more and it makes you discontent
okay but God has given me contentment
he's giving me peace he's giving me love
even to my enemies and when I've gone
through difficulties he has carried me
through and he's been stood next to me
okay I know my experience is genuine the
person in my life is God okay Richard I
would personally say why he is Muslim
heavily Islam you know religion in your
home and we live together important is
not Muslim say one must say do you say
that say that is anything said you know
my one minute I'm finish we have to live
together law does matter watch both
looks
Moose's what love Jesus what love
Muhammad would love the whole book love
no one messenger bought something kill
each other yes so what we can live
together that is the rules that is love
whatever you believe in your home I live
together
I agree
the finger wanted to say thing I wanted
to say is that you said that you went
through certain things in life
obsession made you a better person I can
see exactly seem to you
I came to Islam my life change I was
living for other people I was a slave to
my society yes there's no issue it work
Jewish works for you a man works for me
I'm in no way shape or form here trying
to force you to my way of life and it's
trying to reason with you hopefully I
hope I don't come across I'm trying to
enforce you I'm sure the reason being a
voluntary principle yes yes Iran has
free will exactly we believe in Liberty
solutions and people of was because you
were asking
Christopher about the Bible and the
Bible and he was talking about he was
talking about Jesus and Mohammed and
then he came to the Bible I just wanted
to make that point that the one of the
differences between Islam and
Christianity is you make a big deal out
of believing in the Koran which are
respect but we don't make a big deal out
of believing the Bible we make a deal
as you can see we're having nice
frequent discussions here we're trying
to get rid of that ego you know trying
to win arguments we're not here for that
we're here to genuinely discuss with
people learn share the message my job is
to convey the message only the change
nobody's heart so inshallah I was being
discussion Richard hope you guys have
benefited in shala - next time Salaam
alaikum whatever